il ya aussi un phénomène sociologique
c'est que on le voit bien à travers ces
manifestations
ce sont surtout les grandes villes le
centre des grandes villes et donc c'est
une sociologie très particulière de
jeunes donc jusqu'à à peu près 35 ans de
jeunes branchés connecter un peu fasciné
par la culture occidentale par qui
souhaitent voyager qu'ils souhaitent
plus de liberté et ça c'est une réalité
beaucoup de jeunes se reconnaissent dans
la personnalité de navalni et puis il ya
un troisième facteur qui joue en sa
faveur
et là qui dépasse largement les laisser
ces secteurs sociologique ou général
générationnel dont je parle c'est son
thème de combat la lutte contre la
corruption
quand on va en russie tout le monde
parle de la corruption et tout le monde
a l'impression d'être mal payé et d'être
dirigés par des gens qui volent l'argent
que ce soit des gens dans
l'administration dans la politique des
élus et c est donc ce thème de la
corruption est très populaire et touche
tout le monde y compris des partisans de
vladimir poutine et du pouvoir et
navalni a très bien joué dans cette
affaire il a mis le doigt sur le seul
élément qui peut lui a tiré une
popularité une sympathie parce que pour
le reste ça a été dit il n'a aucun
programme
il est il à il a beaucoup et ré de de la
gauche ou ou de l'extrême gauche à
l'extrême droite de l'échiquier
politique russe il n'est pas jugé
crédible comme opposants il est jugé
crédible quand il dénonce et je termine
avec ça il a été très malin parce que
jusqu'à maintenant les russes considéré
que beaucoup de gens s'enrichissent et
de façon illicite qui avait beaucoup de
corruption mais poutine on le voit dans
les sondages été relativement épargnée
et là avec site cette histoire un peu
fantasmatique du du palais du palace
attribué à poutine il le met nommément
dans la cour des plus grands corrompus
de la russie et là il peut faire mal
même si les russes décrypte tout ça
c'est bien en tout cas ce qui fait la
majorité de l'électorat russe c'est à
dire au delà des centres villes des
centres urbains et des plus jeunes
générations
[Musique]